now our next honoree has been a frequent
object of
over the years at Academy events and it
is an extreme privilege for me to have a
chance to say a little bit about the
great general uns
as selfishly she is an actress who has
had the most profound influence on my
work now it's a blessing to be able to
work in both film and theatre but when I
see the work of Jenna Rowland's the
intense authenticity and the immediacy
of her acting seems to me to be the
closest that anyone has ever come to
capturing on film that special quality
that presence of a live stage
performance there is quite simply no
membrane between Jenna and her audience
she makes me forget entirely that she's
actually not inside my brain and until
seeing her on film I had never
experienced and it is an experience
watching Jenna Rowland's on film have
never experienced this style of acting
so Jenna for what you have given me for
what you have given all of us and
perhaps most importantly what you have
given to the craft of acting a very deep
and sincere eternal thank you